a divided community
can be a dangerous community edmonton
police chief dale mcphee has been
calling for calm he has described the
political divisions highlighted by covet
19 policy as a fire i'm asking and
imploring political leaders community
members
everyone across the spectrum to help us
put this fire out but the fires continue
to rage on parliament hill divisions are
clear in edmonton on wednesday a staff
member at a liberal mp's edmonton office
was attacked the person who did show up
was a self-declared unvaccinated person
who was there to protest
and
and then the assault took place rhetoric
from leaders has been just as heated
this response comes from a question from
a jewish mp conservative party members
can stand with people who wave swastikas
they can stand with people who wave the
confederate flag the house speaker
admonished the prime minister for that
remark later former mayors criticized
premier jason kenney for fanning the
flames of divisiveness after a tweet on
pipeline protests and david suzuki
university of alberta sociologist amy
kaler says it has been a long time since
we've experienced this kind of a divide
the first thing that comes to mind maybe
because it's almost exactly 100 years
ago is if you look at the descent and
divergent opinions and views around
the first world war conscription the
good news here kaler says this time the
divisions might not be as deep we hear
from those most upset but kaler says
most people aren't like that the bad
news all that noise could make it harder
to find common ground seeing these
things almost gives a sort of permission
effect for them to continue because yeah
it's real i saw somebody can do it we've
done it so you know let's keep doing it
and it'll take a while i think for that
to
die down meaning says kaler some views
need to change and like chief mcphee
says so too does the rhetoric krisha
khan global news